zeigen sie mir mal wenn der schmerz
kommt können sie noch reden und weiter
atmen
ich habe rp retinitis pigmentosa das ist
eben eine erbkrankheit die zu einem
tunnelblick führt also ich hab noch sage
ich mal bis zum morgen 30 35 10
lebensjahr noch recht gut gesehen bin
auch noch fahrrad gefahren
die meisten patienten die ich hier habe
wissen es gar nicht wenn ich dann sage
ja ich bin sogar vom gesetz her blind
dann sagt das glauben sie nicht
ja man kann sehr vieles überspielen
also man wird weltmeister in überspielen
ich habe natürlich meine mitarbeiter
geschult und hab gesagt ihr dürft nicht
irgendwas verstellen
dann werde ich wahnsinnig wenn ich
irgendwie stunden danach was suchen muss
wenn man einfach nur mal so nach hinten
greifen wo immer die rolle liegt und die
liegt dann da nicht und dann fängt man
da an zu suchen also dass meine eltern
haben mich darin immer unterstützt die
haben nie gesagt das kannst du nicht das
schaffst du nicht
ich hätte mein mann nicht kennen gelernt
wenn ich es weil ich die sehbehinderung
nicht hätte also ich habe schon immer
gerne fußball gespielt und habe mich
dann zu einem blindenfußball workshop
hier in berlin angemeldet und den hat
damals mein mann organisiert wo ich
jetzt auch mit meinem sohn halte auch
fußball spielen kann ja widmeten klingel
ball berlin an sich ist sehr laut sehr
voll
der ellenbogen bezogen dass es ist echt
eine herausforderung hier in berlin
ich sehe also hell und dunkel und grobe
umrisse also wenn ich jetzt hier in der
halle mich umschaue dann sehe ich die
fenster ich sehe die publikum landen
sozusagen als helle flecken und da kann
man sich schon auch ganz gut orientieren
die stufen ansicht die taste ich mit
meinem stock und ansonsten kenne ich
natürlich dieses gebäude hier einfach
auch ziemlich gut mit den ganzen gängen
und winkeln und wir sehen verlaufen sich
ja immer sehr gern und finden auch nicht
wieder alleine heraus bereits im alter
von elf jahren als ich selbst beim
rechtsanwalt war war ich so begeistert
davon dass es nie ein thema war etwas
anderes zu machen als jura es ist ja so
dass justitia ja immer mit einer
augenbinde gezeigt wird und bei mir ist
es so dass natürlich auch durch das
nicht vorhandene sehvermögen ich die
leute auf jeden fall nicht nach dem
äußeren beurteilen kann dadurch eben
auch mich nicht ablenken lassen kann und
sehr fokussiert bin auf das was die
leute hier sagen aber ich bin natürlich
trotzdem nicht ganz frei von vorurteilen
also blinde menschen bilden sich wenn
sie vorteile haben sie natürlich dann
einfach auf anderer ebene wenn einem
jetzt die stimmen nicht gefällt oder
einem händedruck nicht gefällt also ich
bin kein lebender lügendetektor oder
sowas aber ich habe schon auch ein
gespür dafür ja dass die leute mir sagen
ob das stimmt oder ob das gelungen
solange man sich nicht vorstellen kann
dass in berlin darauf treppensteigen
kann wie soll ich mir dann vorstellen
dass ein blinder und sehbehinderter sich
in der arbeitswelt zurechtfinden kann
ich bin von geburt an blind wenn ich
unterwegs bin und ich sagte also sprich
fahrt zur arbeit und dann kommt der satz
fahren sie jetzt in die werkstatt und es
müsste eigentlich der satz kommt was
arbeiten sie denn daran merkt man
eigentlich wie viele vorurteile noch
abgebaut werden müssen
die drei teile dienst im grunde nur der
korrektur sage ich mal
und über die hauptsache höre ich wenn
wörter falsch geschrieben sind über die
sprachausgabe und jetzt habe ich ihn
einfach diese zeile aus also das ist
mitarbeiterin dass schiri hatten sich
bringen sie mal hier
das merken sie hier ist nichts luke ist
immer frei er kann zu lesen in der
digitalen welt ist es so die technik ist
fluch und segen zugleich
natürlich gibt es auch schon einige
webseiten die für uns gut bedienbar sind
aber auch immer noch viel zu viele die
nicht barrierefrei sind
wann kommt der 221 genau dafür wurde ich
mir jetzt die abfahrt ran
aber das ist dann schon für den nicht
mehr hier zu erkennen und er zeigt mir
hier verspätet in zehn minuten wenigsten
das heißt der jetzt gerade ankommt den
den zeigt er mir schon gar nicht mehr an
bord
ich bin jetzt noch mal in der stadt ja
weil hier die anbindung des öffentlichen
personennahverkehrs gegeben ist und das
ist ja das was mich flexibel macht ich
meine sollten wir eines tages die
autonomen autos haben und dann kann ich
mir eines leichten so gar nicht mehr das
alles für mich wäre das super und dann
kann mir überlegen ob ich aufs land
ziehen kann